weather for ducks is what they say in
england when it rains
well this is anything but
it's the driest summer for 50 years
grass has shriveled to straw the ground
has cracked reservoirs and rivers are
low and drought has officially been
declared across large parts of england
in some areas there are water companies
bringing in place for instance temporary
use ban so-called hosepipe bans
that's the right thing for those
companies to do where they have
particular concerns
and it's a small sacrifice for people to
make in order to ensure that we've got
adequate water resources next year from
space the parched conditions are just as
obvious the picture on the left is july
last year a normal enough summer on the
right august 2022 from greens to browns
and yellows
a couple of months ago where i'm
standing now would have been the water
line of rushmere pond on wimbledon
common but now look at it you have to go
a good 15 or so meters this way to get
to the new water line
this pond is now little more than a
puddle and this is happening across
large parts of the country with water
systems like this becoming extremely
stressed
stressed enough here for the fish to
barely have enough water to cover them
it's worrying stuff for anyone paying
attention
i find it very sad
you know nature the ground is so hard
the
birds can't have the worms there's
nothing around
when you see things like that pond
you realize how different it is in this
grain of the grass and
yeah quite serious does it worry
it starts to hit home last month england
experienced its hottest ever temperature
40.3 degrees
the 10 hottest years since 1884 have all
happened since 2002 and none of the
coldest this summer may turn out to be
an anomaly but the data suggests not
and that means more fires more extreme
temperatures and more droughts to come
rory challenge how to zero london